[Music]
I'll be very honest with you when I do
dr. King and I'm performing is as if dr.
King takes over it's like the spirit of
dr. King comes into the road if you
listen to the majority of his speeches
right now he's right in line with what
we're dealing with today
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is Stefan Ferguson I travel
across the world performing his the
Reverend dr. Martin Luther King jr. I am
the only person who is licensed by the
king of state to perform the works of
dr. King I used to be a DJ we took some
of dr. King's old records and as we were
mixing them in I began to emulate some
of dr. King's old records particularly I
have a dream a good friend of mine said
man you sound just like dr. King you
should really consider taking your work
to another level I realized that it was
a gift that God had given me to continue
the work and the legacy of dr. King
let's read a brief
from the prodigious hilltops of New
Hampshire let freedom ring I've been
performing as dr. King for about 15
years get a lot of requests to perform
in different areas from Madrid Spain
London England
I've been honoured to get recognition
from a lot of great people President
Barack Obama reached out to me I have a
letter thanking me for my work so that
was a very powerful recognition I've
even got that from King family members
I speak for the entire family that we
know of no one who can actually sound
like my own children his cadence is
unique it has a slow southern drawl to
it but a sophistication at the same time
and Stefan just really flatters us all
with the way that he's able to bring my
uncle's voice back to life
I believe it resonates with people
because we're living in a time that we
needed with all the hatred the divisive
mnestheus e in the world I think it
really inspires people to stand up to
speak out I may get to the age where
it's gonna be difficult but I'll still
be trying to do it
[Music]
we're a big group of strong women that
takes risks riding motorcycles all the
time in the city which takes a set of
steel ovaries in my opinion but we want
to help babies who says no to babies the
club delivers process and pasteurized
donor breast milk to mothers and babies
in need both to Nick use in hospitals
and to private homes we focus our
service on the women's health issues so
this is complete fit for what we try to
do as a club the call for milk can come
at any time you can be anywhere we pull
up to the dock at the New York milk Bank
Julie brings out the milk that's been
prepackaged in freezer bags and boxes we
strap it down to the motorcycles this is
it the way when we opened up the milk
bank
I was actually stuck in traffic with my
husband and saw a motorcycle rider
illegally driving up the center lane and
I thought why can't we use motorcyclists
to deliver milk in and out of New York
we collected from women that have an
excess amount of milk we process it test
it and distribute it to hospitals for
premature infants and to the community
at large Marla was born four months
early I brought Marlo home after a
hundred and sixty-one days in the NICU I
stopped producing breast milk and all of
Marlo's doctors required Marlo to
continue on breast milk because putting
her on formula would gravely endanger
her life I had to find a way to be able
to give my daughter breast milk and I
found donor milk since then we've been
getting deliveries from the milk bank we
get delivery once a month it's three
hundred and thirty bottles of three
ounces
the sound of the motorcycles is the
sound of hope they're bringing life
liquid life or a small baby ooh I don't
know every time I give Marlo a bottle I
start to think about what's in there
it's not just one woman's work I know
the hard work energy labor love
dedication and sacrifice that goes into
every ounce we don't waste a drop around
here it's priceless
I think the homeless in general just
feel that they've been completely
forgotten by society that nobody cares
about them nobody cares if they wake up
tomorrow they might even feel like they
think that people hope that they don't
wake up tomorrow and I didn't think that
anybody should have to feel like that so
I decided that when I became a PA that I
wanted to focus on on the homeless
population
[Music]
so street medicine is really a program
that was born out of the idea that
everybody matters we see that there are
certain segments of the population that
just don't access health care the way
everybody else does
[Music]
because Allentown is a relatively small
city it is still surrounded by woods so
most of the homeless you're not going to
see sleeping outside on the street so
they go live in the woods in tents so
that's usually where we have to go to
find our patients I have a backpack with
over 20 medications we have an EKG
machine we do point-of-care testing or
we could get different bloodwork the
whole idea is to deliver quality care
on-site in a place where the patient
feels comfortable
[Music]
do you still have that inhaler Mike yeah
how often are you using it why not -
over 68 everything we do is completely
free we provide free medications free
labs free diagnostic studies so they
don't need insurance and we have the
same incredible people that see them all
the time
they get to know us and trust us and
we're lucky enough that they allow us to
help them okay just breathe normal
doing this job can be extremely
difficult you just see things that are
really hard to see and and sometimes
feel helpless but one of the things that
that I always try to do is just try and
completely forget myself in it to
remember that this is not about me at
all it's just about the patients it
doesn't matter if I'm tired it doesn't
matter if I'm frustrated with trying to
help somebody it just doesn't matter
about me it matters about them so I try
and focus on them and their needs
[Music]
particular capacity purple own to access
transport ah she would sahaja get Akali
[Music]
Karnataka scientifically figure several
Americans as well to determine the man
Terry muscle he ended up with a pan
transfer fancy nama saya trio knocks but
Ponder's starting to see a teepee
Pacifica and transform ya da Cunha give
up will swap if you got time kita priori
tossed Waianae together at random
ultimately bubble Mugen your teeth get a
suit under a fan dairy products food in
mouth + / - are you two together if you
wanna run young cuckoo cuckoo on gooses
young cricketer openly sassy [ __ ]
command Amalia is the lanyard applause
applause office a Gotama finish I see it
is difficult even of bangin over that
the truth - thumper and Caputo a lien
arose capacity - ketta motor and
releasing the exact - single sip and
although the party took in satellite
even but we'll check in the war zero dad
blew it defied approach Allah Rakha it's
a visa program a career depression you
know given appropriate strategies and
enter America come on a little trois
Polan lacki
katana brann bergen i can impact a
superstar in a study of alien workers
awakening
[Music]
my friend can go wherever the union
really has place for us effectively all
of India it was the first possible plane
needs
[Music]
lifeline Express has been around for
about 25 years there has been over a
million patient encounters since
obstructed and over a hundred thousand
surgeries
I am dr. Luke Gorzelanny I'm a
neurologist the mission has been to take
medical services to the people wherever
deprivation disability and poverty
coexisted rural India doesn't really
have much of healthcare facilities
lifeline Express has operation theaters
and area for consultations and minor
procedures and coaches fault
office space and so on the lifeline
Express focuses on cataract surgeries
issues like cleft lip and cleft palate
epilepsy breast and oral cancer and
Family Planning before the project
happens there is publicity in the
markets in the town then there are
posters put up there are patients that
are coming around from the surrounding
areas there are some days when I've seen
close to 100 patients already at every
project we get at least about 25 to 30
volunteer doctors and then there are
about 25 to 30 doctors who come in from
the location itself our patients are
grateful for what
and I see it as a way to give back
I think empathy letting them know that
whatever is possible is being done and
more importantly hearing them out it all
is part of the healing process
[Music]